[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et trahison deux mots qui peuvent à peu
près résumés
autant qu'elle soulève des patients elle
divise en Grande-Bretagne versus
l'Amérique le couple en fait le dit dès
le début le voulait raconter sa vérité
vous leur répliquez à tout ce qu'ils ont
vécu alors les ingrédients d'une bonne
histoire c'est quoi c'est la haine c'est
le racisme la jalousie les rivalités
l'intimidation les enjeux de santé
mentales aussi et leur histoire est
malmenée évidemment par une presse très
malveillante mais quel est l'intérêt de
leur histoire et de leurs intrigues de
filles devenu un véritable cauchemar
alors pour en parler de chacun Marc
Laurendeau journaliste bonsoir alors
c'est quoi l'intérêt d'une série de
raconter des
intérêts vraiment plusieurs mais
l'intérêt journalistique et d'intérêt
public je dirais c'est de savoir si ces
révélations vont ébranler le trône
d'Angleterre à quelques mois du
couronnement de Charles III alors vous
les disiez c'est l'heure vérité et
justement ça souffre de ça je pense que
cette Syrie pour avoir regardé tous les
épisodes ça souffre de
regard extérieur c'est on aimerait comme
souvent quand dans un documentaire il y
a un regard autre qui qui départage les
choses qui conseillent c'est leur vérité
et il y a un paradoxe aussi parce que il
trouve qu'on attaque beaucoup leur vie
privée mais par ailleurs ils étendent
leur vie privée beaucoup il y a une
contradiction là-dedans j'ajouterai
aussi que tout est dans l'émotion ils ne
veulent plus faire partie de ce monde
dit-il il dénonce ce monde de
célébrité royale mais en même temps les
enfants un peu parti ils veulent encore
d'une certaine manière en fait partie
voyez un certain nombre de
contradictions mais malgré ces
contradictions malgré le côté il y a un
côté caramel aussi un côté c'est du
caramel dégoulinant alors où on aime
parce qu'on a de l'empathie et on reçoit
on reçoit les messages de Mégane sur la
santé mentale avec beaucoup de avec
beaucoup de compassion et en même temps
on se demande si c'est leur vérité c'est
une mise en scène parce que on a accès à
leur intimité grâce à vos vidéos
personnelles à des images jamais on a eu
accès à ces questions là donc le
paradoxe est complet
le prince avec son bébé on le voit
faisant du jardinage et on les voit
s'embrassant dans l'intimité beaucoup
plus qu'on a vu d'autres couples
principaux
et puis le fond de l'affaire c'est
qu'ils disent que dès qu'ils ont
commencé à faire des tournées en
Nouvelle-Zélande et en Australie ils ont
capté les projecteurs on dirait
familièrement chez nous il volait le
chaud et il faut pas faire ça la famille
royale le projecteur doit être sur
l'héritier ou sur le dépôt stère de la
couronne le roi lui-même ou la reine
mais pas sur les personnages secondaires
ou tertiaires et ils étaient tellement
populaire que William a souffrait
Charles en souffrait même la reine en
prenait ombrage dit-on alors là sur leur
version beaucoup de des petites rumeurs
coulaient à la presse comme quoi elle
était une diva harceler le personnel à
Buckingham etc et tout ça s'accélérait
on la presse jaunisse et collaborent du
documentaire c'est que il peut y avoir
beaucoup la famille royale alimente la
preuve jaunisse la rencontre
périodiquement et c'est ça qui les a
vraiment irrité parce que après la
presse évidemment il y a des médias
sociaux qui s'en mêlent alors ils ont
été oui ébranlés partout mais c'est ça
la secte la trame de fond c'est la
persécution qu'avec Diana à l'époque où
faisait des difficultés elle était bon
même les paparazzis étaient sur ces
traces quand elle est morte et Harry
fait le parallèle
Ariana et sa femme Mégane qui pour qu'il
ne veut pas qu'elle vive la même chose
ni ses enfants donc ils veulent sortir
la famille royale alors c'est là que ça
m'a encore tu peux pas sortir la famille
royale tes dents ou tu es en dehors puis
lui proposait une solution mitoyenne et
c'est là que les rivalités que les
trahisons sont survenues marques c'est
la version la version de de Charles ou
de la reine
tandis que eux voulaient peut-être être
au Canada ou en Nouvelle-Zélande ou en
Australie pour parce que la presse ni là
je sais pas sur des questions de race
d'ailleurs c'est c'était très malicieux
et alors il voulait il proposait une
entente comme quoi ils agacent leurs
fonctions mais en étant pas tout à fait
si vous voulez un sel et Charles était
furieux présentait et c'est une
révélation aussi présentait ça à la
reine comme une espèce d'attaque contre
le pouvoir royal William je dis bien
William lui criait par la tête il dit ça
lui crier par la tête lors des
discussions à Sandrine lorsqu'il devait
justement négocier les modalités c'est
ça et donc ça a été très brutal
tellement brutal d'ailleurs que c'est
sorti la presse et ils ont sorti un
communiqué disant que bucking commun
que ça avait été brutal
alors vous voyez mensonge couvert pour
protéger son frère dans les extraits
qu'on voit
ça c'est le coeur de la faire plus les
questions passent la question de race
c'est ça c'est que eux disent
Mégane aurait pu être une
icône elle est une icône on dit elle est
devenue une grande vedette elle est très
aimée et elle aurait pu dans le fond
permettre à la famille royale de se
réformer de ce moderniser des inclusive
de représenter le commonw 2 milliards et
demi de citoyens or la l'institution
comme il l'appelle dans le documentaire
son apaisant documentaire est inflexible
je sais pas si c'est une justification
apostériori mais elle est valable que
vous dites 2.7 milliards des noirs ou
des bruns en majorité et puis ça
commence à débarquer du commonwalt ou du
moins de l'adhésion à la couronne à la
Barbade la Jamaïque et beaucoup dans les
Caraïbes et puis ailleurs aussi on remet
en question la monarchie alors c'est
important si on a des dans la famille
royale des noix après tout la fortune de
la Grande-Bretagne c'est bâti en
spalliant ces pays-là c'est dans le film
les pays du commonwald que j'enregistrer
se fondait en 49 comme association ont
été spolies alors ça sera la moindre des
choses qu'elle vendent des Noirs dans
famille royale c'est ce qu'il dit on
verra la suite mais c'est une histoire
d'amour conte de fées qui devient un
cauchemar il s'en vont et c'est un peu
la misère des riches non parce qu'il
part dans un palais à Londres ou à
sanrigan ou Windsor les s'en vont dans
des palais grande maison à Santa Barbara
contrat de 100 millions à Netflix alors
et d'autres projets une biographie qui
va sortir au fond donc ça va susciter
quel
culture hollywoodienne
qu'ils affichent comme vous dites c'est
la misère des riches il y a un homme
d'affaires qui fait voyager jet privé et
puis qui les installe c'est à Santa
Barbara c'est pas tout le monde
alors qu'est-ce que ça va faire pour la
famille royale ici à la question que je
posais au départ un grand Bretagne on
dit
c'est pas une bombe c'est pas non plus
une brique mais c'est certainement une
pierre dans la fenêtre de Buckingham
Palace alors ça va égratigner et Charles
et pas déjà si populaire
maintenant et donc ça va pas discréditer
totalement la famille royale
entendons-nous mais
ça hygratting certainement les gens vont
voir ça en tête là quand l'histoire
d'amour en parlant
des devoirs 8 avec Diana et avec avec
Mégane aujourd'hui ça fait partie de
l'histoire de la famille royale
dans 6 heures de documentaire qui accuse
son frère son père même sa grand-mère de
possibilités il y a une grande tristesse
aussi là-dedans non on peut le voir
comme ça mais on peut le voir comme la
réparation d'une injustice usine il
force pas de lui là dedans et c'est le
plus franc monsieur des deux
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]